it's an absolute honor to meet all four
of these ladies it's pretty cool
experience it's really a once in a
lifetime opportunity for me to be in
their presence to see them act you know
they are really the goats in what they
do smoking in the Bandit was one of my
favorite movies and I just watched
Forrest Gump the other day and just the
opportunity to talk to her work with her
see how she works it's awesome I told
her I was taking all the notes I can and
soaking it up it was just adorable
I've been watching Danny I've been
watching Julian go
it's just hysterical just seeing them
play their part he's cute Mara who did
you pick she finds a cut out of one of
the football players and she just thinks
he's the cutest thing that ever happened
the first thing on my list was I wanted
Rita to actually touch my beard and I'm
checking it off after this I can retire
and just go sit on a beach hopefully